on était nombreux à quoi que le
présentéisme c'est le fait d'être
présent au travail mais diffèrent des
tâches personnelles sur l'ordinateur du
bureau des tâches impertinente
or c'est souvent loin d'être une juste
description de la réalité travailleurs
qui souffre de présentéisme veulent dans
les fait travailler le plus fort
possible mais leur état de santé
physique ou psychologique ne leur permet
pas obligé d'être au travail
pour toutes les personnes malades oui
mais on en parle aussi de manière plus
générale le choix diane gabrielle
tremblay de la téluq de la
télé-université au québec et spécialiste
des questions du travail et du
télétravail pour avoir une proportion on
veut être vu par les patrons par contre
est monté dans l'organisation et ont vu
qu' on n'est pas là dans trois mois et
vu les entreprises ou s'il ya de la
concurrence pour être compétitif il faut
que nous on enfin que donc elles font
pression sur les salariés beaucoup des
professionnels ou des techniciens et fox
pour voir un peu les deux côtés outils
il ya beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs une
recherche qui a été fait par la
commission des normes du travail qui
montre que dans l'économie du savoir
justement donc que le gilet formation
par exemple multimédia sur les
professeurs aussi beaucoup d un contrat
également les gens vont faire de plus
longues leur présenter je le fait de se
présenter au travail malgré un état qui
est très bavard mais que ce soit pour
des soins associés toi la santé physique
ou mentale dans les costumes grenet et
vice président de l'entreprise at monde
qu une compagnie montréalaise
spécialisée dans la gestion du personnel
nous chez athmane quand on travaille
avec différentes entreprises et
certaines vont avoir des philosophique
en plus en mai qu'il y travaille famille
ils vont le mettre dans leurs valeurs et
maintenant certaines compétences
par contre dans certaines de nos
entreprises on a encore la tendance qui
est de deux bellâtres on cherche une
certaine view et on veut vraiment non
seulement dévoué l'équivoque malgré
l'adversité aller plus loin et souvent
c'est ensuite une entreprise qu'on va
avoir tendance à pousser un peu plus
loin que la ligne tht accepta donc et
vous serez sans solde pour que peu
importe qu'il arrive elle
avant goût de la fente et qu'il peut
produire mais dans les faits de l'humain
et a pas un rebond et ça l'amène
déplacement au niger vont se présenter
au boulot ne sont pas en mesure d'être
auditifs au travail effet l'argent
d'autres conséquentes par la fuite pour
qu'il y ait du présentéisme il doit y
avoir un étang de santé affaiblie
qu'il s'agisse d'un manque de sommeil
épisodique causés par exemple par un
enfant malade pendant la nuit
qu'il s'agisse aussi d'une grippe ou un
autre extrême d'une détresse
psychologique d'une blessure physique ou
encore d'une maladie sérieuse un
présenter east est donc souvent
quelqu'un sous le coup d'un grand stress
aux malades qui s'ignorent ou encore qui
choisit de s'ignorer exemple
l'absentéisme est très mal vu dans le
milieu de la cuisine professionnelle par
conséquent quand un chef est malade il
continue la plupart du temps de se
présenter au travail ce qui peut avoir
des conséquences graves pour les clients
pour le restaurant la critique canadien
en gastronomie
leslie certainement un coup énorme on
parle dans les études d étude américaine
1 2 3 fois
les études britanniques jusqu'à 10 fois
plus élevés que les coûts d'une absence
justifiée
pierrette desrosiers et psychologue et
coach d'affaires et conférencière elle
connaît bien les enjeux du présentéisme
au travail parce que c'est ce qu'on se
dit on est mieux d'être l'homme de
paille clos mais en fait à cause des
conséquences directes et indirectes ça
coûterait trop points à 10 fois plus
cher dont un entrepreneur qui vivent
dans ce que si une énorme ferme dont on
parle de millions de dollars
il entre dans l'institution financière
pour rencontrer quelqu'un est la
personne qui est à l'accueil
sauf de présentéisme on le sait par la
suite à cause de l'histoire mais leur
garde et très impoli très impatiente et
perd le regarde en train d'écouter
monsieur chapron a rendez vous le pensez
pas qu'on soit ici sans rendez vous pour
qui vous vous prenez pour leurs gardes
d'une façon un peu dédaigneuse parce que
monsieur ce n'est pas nécessairement
changer et bref le monsieur m'a raconté
cette histoire il a pris ses millions
qu'il était chez le groupe et qui tarde
à côté alors c'est une journée au
travail que coûter cher vous comprenez
pour l'institution financière
éric beaulieu
les conseillers en orientation
professionnelle au québec parce que
c'est un modèle qui est en voie d'être
mise à quai dans son regard des
générations y était en train de monter
un général attentes que j'ai donc écouté
avec que ça paraît entacher des
avantages une médaille a toujours deux
phases
mais sur le côté avantageux césaire non
on veut plus suivre le modèle où on
confond performer a pu connaître au
point sur un malade justement alors je
pense que ce modèle là il est un
questionnement je pense qu'ils
organisent à 100 les structures sont à
même de commencer à consciente des trois
puits sont peut-être pas encore assez
outils avec une vision stratégique et et
de gens pour peut-être intervenait
prévenir un reportage de radio canada
international